you see them on joe rogan and he'll kill
tony make some noise
[Music]
i
cannot [ __ ] her
for many different reasons
one of them being she's married
hey look at the wheels
distract it
distract you from my sexuality
number two
wow
we're gonna pick uh a card from here
let's pick it randomly
where are you guys from you're like
middle eastern but you're wearing a
cowboy hat
are you pretending you're mexican
drugs you'll know about this
drugs
don't put a bus
mexico
no i love uh doing more drugs i can do
more drugs and i will do more drugs
drugs around shrubs all day uh if you
can tell i'm on drugs right now
i'm on alcohol you guys ever tried
alcohol
i'm on like two tabs with alcohol right
now
alcohol is a drug i know you guys with
your judeo-christian morality or like
alcohol is just what we do on every day
to beat my wife
but alcohol is a [ __ ] drug it's a
drug drugs
you know what
you know what i love about drugs is it
gives you another perspective on life
because most of the time we're going
through life with a sober brain uh most
of us who aren't homeless but then if
you do drugs you get like oh another
brain brain number two and then you
could be like oh look at brain number
one you know from over here i'm looking
at brain number one and then you can get
an objective
oh my god why are you heckling just
because you're from mexico
sounds like a sci-fi movie yeah welcome
to america we don't like just [ __ ]
worship the sun god or touch a comma or
whatever
we're uh you know we use your country
for uh cheap consumer goods and now we
get talk about better than you because
you make soap operas that are really
cheesy
i like him if i could understand it i
might like him but the plot's pretty
basic and uh the women are very hot
they all look like nausea
yeah i love it
you got the hottest girl saying the
stupidest [ __ ] of soap operas
hey
she won't [ __ ] me
no i love soap operas i wish they did a
little acid maybe like get some aliens
in that [ __ ] can you imagine like a
novella with aliens do they have that
mexico
hey
look at that
[Music]
no i love mexican people
you know they're
a great
one
cancel culture
la cultura de cancellationo
no i love cancer culture you know
who doesn't love just denying things
that exist because they exist
you exist now you don't now you're
nothing
that is a good way to deal with society
you think you are here but you're not
you actually are zero and we actually
don't want anything from you uh please
don't exist anymore as a human being
that's a healthy way to deal with your
problems someone annoys you
deny their existence
[Music]
but there's seven billion of us you know
we don't need everybody we need to
cancel some people
no i believe in neurodiversity i think
everyone should contribute their little
weird brains into the melting pot of our
consciousness and we mix it around and
see what we get as a whole and average
it out or like the median or something
and i think that a lot of people are not
that creative or like diverse and they
just like trying to be like a black dude
or like a fratty douchebag and we we
need all different types we need like
middle eastern people wearing cowboy
hats we need this guy who's like a
strong white man
and he's got a beard and he's like very
sensitive you know like we need all
types we can't just have like strong
white dudes just being sad and like
grumpy we need we need strong white
dudes who are sensitive and love
butterflies
[Applause]
you know what's funny about this wheel i
mentioned it last time i was on here but
it's one and two you've got like 17
different things for one and two you
could just flip a coin
why do we need a whole wheel for one and
two
i'm guessing this is two
that's what you're good for thank you
audience
you're very useful don't let anyone tell
you any different
coming quick
but it smell like coming like the uh
electronics manufacturer cummings
uh coming quick
i i just don't have any idea what that's
about
no
just kidding
i did it yesterday
um coming quick you know it's like
evolutionarily if you have the ability
to impregnate and inseminate a woman you
don't want to like take forever and then
eventually like the husband comes in
you're like what the [ __ ] are you doing
oh sorry i didn't come quick so
evolutionarily you're designed to on the
first blow just to be like
[Music]
but uh you shouldn't because the lady
won't have you back again and you're
probably wearing a condom but she's not
birth control so you won't get the
impregnator so you gotta like think
ahead of your body and be like i know
you want to put a baby in her but just
wait and you may be
able to put a baby in her later
but uh really uh modern sex is not about
impregnation or creating a baby it's
about connection
and
awesome time
dot com
so
you know like try to out think your
primal
uh instincts and just be like
okay i know i want to come right now but
let's also make sure she's having an
awesome time
and you should just like keep pumping
away and keep
you know the more you pump the better
she feels until she gets dry and then
just friction
but
until it gets to that point
you got to keep
keep at it you know like think of the
woman it's like sex is about the
amalgamation of two people it's not just
about your orgasm it's about her orgasm
so like i try to last uh like a medium
amount of time but you also i think
coming quick is better than coming not
at all so i try to come
medium late
no i love coming
i think we should come quick
better than not coming at all
but yeah coming quickly it's so
embarrassing when you're like oh my god
you're so attractive that you made me
come quick and most girls they don't
really
like sex that much so it's like oh thank
you you know it's a compliment it's like
they don't really need to come they're
like oh yeah you complimented me by
coming quickly so it's like that's
that's cool too but uh not that girl she
loves
coming as well with the man so like it
depends on what kind of girl you're with
like if she wants to like you know
experience sex
as more than just a social symbolic
thing then it's like yeah you gotta like
deliver the uh sexual experience so you
gotta like hold it
you know you gotta hold it
you gotta keep it tight
i just i just did a key goal right then
i think that's what a kegel is uh so
yeah coming quickly it can be overcome
with strength training you know
everyone's training their biceps but no
one's training their
dick flap
whatever's in your dick
that like regulates the flow
that's why
so i like to go to the bathroom and just
regulate my piss flow you know
i do morris code with my test in the
bathroom
and then when i'm with the girl i can
just be like
and then
[Music]
right
thanks
um you guys
ever think about
i have no idea what the [ __ ] can you
read what this says
tell a story
wow this middle easterner is better in
english than i am
congratulations
your assimilation is perfect you will be
able to blend in and bomb a song
i love you guys
thank you
um
once upon a time i was a small child
only 32 years old
and i was living in a van
as we all do from time to time right you
know what i'm talking about
uh i was living in a van and i uh
attached a solar panel onto the top of
my roof but i only use velcro because
i uh i
was uh yeah and then i drove on i-35
over there and then i was driving and i
heard
and i was like oh [ __ ]
and i went to my destination um
[Music]
some anderson mill pub
pub
up north and uh
i got there and then there was no solar
panel i was like oh [ __ ]
i lost my solar panel on the highway on
i-35
who wants to hear a sex story
one time
what's the what's the best sex story
that i have
um
you know coming i've come a lot you know
it's just so hard to pick of all the
times that i've come
uh sex
oh
sex what a great time we have with sex
this guy [ __ ]
um
so the very first time i came
the first first time i had sex i was 22
sorry that's a little old i know it's
creepy everyone thinks i'm going to
shoot them now when they tell them that
but i came for the first time with a
woman when i was 22 with a powerful
black woman a pbw
and i was uh going to town you know and
i read online that you have to bury the
the dynamic of it like you can't just go
with one speed so i was going fast fast
slow slow fast fast slow so and she
wasn't really enjoy because that's not
your how you're supposed to have sex the
mexican people know they [ __ ] a lot
and what
you guys [ __ ] a lot you're watching me
you're watching your phone you're
[ __ ] watching a telenovela on your
smartphone
pay attention
you know this isn't a goddamn
oh she said shut up
that's aggression we punish aggression
how dare you
make some noise if you're mexican
[Music]
yeah you're the only one you're [ __ ]
you uh played yourself we're gonna
no mexico is a great country thank you
for letting us take texas
um
so
the first time i lost this is a story
about how i lost my virginity and i was
like do you want to know a secret
because she wasn't really feeling it and
i was like you wanted a secret i was
like oh [ __ ] what like that's not a good
thing to hear when you're having sex
with someone and they're like you want
to hear a secret
and then i was like
i'm a virgin
and then she was like oh
i thought you were just lazy
i'm not lazy i'm just inexperienced
and
then we saw each other a couple times
no it was great
she had a good time
uh
but yeah i mean i've never had a
threesome
you're always gonna um single i'm always
gonna be single you don't think there's
any like fours or threes that will marry
me you know there's like a lot of
desperate women out there
are you leaving oh you're getting kicked
out
have fun you can't even stand a comedy
show
you are not fit for society
you're just gonna be with your one
person that's gonna tolerate your
[ __ ] and you're gonna die
no it's fine
she's mexican she has like a thousand of
those like her back where she's
know from gives a [ __ ] about how i lost
my virginity to a black woman
in atlanta
um i lost my virginity to a black woman
in atlanta
and
she was like are you i thought you were
lazy and i was like no i'm just a virgin
like i never had sex before until now
and then she was like oh thank god
you're not lazy you're just
a loser that has never had sex before
thank you
[Applause]